don't be scared relax and snuggle up
it's episode 15 of IMG these shoes look
nice but when you wear two and put your
heels together it looks like oh and here
are some shoes from designer brass
monkey r2d2 Batman Robin Mario Luigi
Woody and Buzz Lightyear and be sure to
match those Buzz Lightyear ones with
your Buzz Lightyear cup no no not that
kind of cup this kind
oh come on oh la la check out the
brunette let's get a little bit closer
good
now how about from a different angle um
okay let's talk about Christmas
whether it's Star Trek nutcrackers a
Pokemon wreath or Tetris presents be
sure to pick up something from wise
Marco comms list of the twenty worst
nativity scenes he's got an egg timer
dogs s'mores and of course this one
where baby Jesus is ducky of Awesome
oh yeah and back to Tetris this is what
happens when you don't get the pieces
you want in the real world but now let's
look at some sexy cats and here's a
squid eating a dog but don't worry the
dogs will get their revenge this picture
actually came from facebook.com slash
vsauce gaming where you guys can view
and submit great stuff for example
what's cooler than being able to park
like this parking a bunch of cars like
this the same vsauce ER who submitted
that picture also reminded us that even
in the frontlines of war there is always
room for x-box are you making your own
paper snowflakes this year we'll cut
them to look like Darth Vader or Boba
Fett and a clone trooper instructions
can be found via a link in the
description where links to everything
can be found
remember minimal superheroes from IMG 14
will checkout minimal Muppets can you
name them all I love the double eye
illusion it gives you a headache because
your brain can't help but want it to
look like a normal face
it's like magic and how about Magic the
Gathering
is this really the pond of uh lemak or
is it Lil Wayne and in closing here are
my favorite books that actually no
kidding really do exist thanks for
watching